وقد اشرف على العمليه وزير الدفاع
وقادت جهاز الامن العام الشباك وكبار
الضباط في رئاسه هيئه الاركان العسكريه
حيث تابعوا تنفيذها من المقر المحصن
للقيادات الامنيه في مقر الجيش والاجهزه
الامنيه ووزاره الدفاع في تل ابيب وكان
رئيس الحكومه بن يمينه نياهو قد صدق على
الخطه واوعى بتنفيذها منذ يوم الجمعه
الماضي وقد يتراس وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
مشاورات امنيه في تل ابيب بمشاركه رئيس
اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي ونائبه ورئيس شعبه
العمليات ورئيس شعبه الاستخبارات العسكريه
وقائد الجبهه الداخليه وكان الوزير
الاسرائيلي اعلن عما وصفه بحاله خاصه في
المناطق المحاذيه لقطاع غزه حيث قرر اغلاق
بعض الطرقات واعتماد تغييرات في حركه
التنقلات على الطرقات في منطقه غلاف غزه
بناء على تقييم للوضع